c'est maintenant
merci vanessa paradis
toi
debout
c'est vrai que ça fait un moment qu à un
moment quand même pas vu une vanessa
paradis le 13 rue de très heureux de
pouvoir donner ça alors lors de notre
première rencontre c'était en 1987
c'était aux bains douches l'émission
s'appelait bande minuit c'était l'année
de joe le taxi et les paroles de la
chanson était détiennent roda-gil
magnéto serge alors là il fille vanessa
comet a vendu de disques est une scène
en vendons pas loin d'un million de
paquets le clin d'oeil le lier aux
valeurs de ce monde après chaque mois
tu peux ne chantait déjà fait 6 ans tu
vas pas de chanter en espagnol en tous
sens pour vous prendre à ce soir voilà
c'est les 20 minutes et en 1987 avec
julien
étienne roda-gil vanessa paradis étienne
roda-gil qui nous a quittés récemment et
pour qui je voudrais qu'on est une une
pensée parce que c'est quelqu'un de tout
à fait important pour nous et pour vous
regard du commun vraiment un type
exceptionnel
on l'a pas dit ici au moment où nous ça
s'est passé parce que c'était comme ça
et ce soir je suis ravi de lui rendre
hommage en votre compagnie walesa
étienne situe en garde comme dix
longueurs magit les regarde parts qu'ils
détiennent
ouais ah oui bien sûr vanessa après cinq
ans d'absence cinéma donc le temps de
faire deux enfants lily rose et jack le
temps d'un cd qui s'appelle bliss et
d'une tournée vous revenez dans un film
absolument barjots une comédie de
science-fiction qui s'appelle atomik
circus le retour de james bataille des
frères poireau
alors c'est un film ovni ascain c'est
complètement un pitch à bhl c'est une
série z déjanté ça se passe dans un
village qui s'appelle côtelettes city un
village rétro-futuriste donc au fin fond
des usa où on prépare une grande fête
c'est la fête de la tarte à la vache
avec une chanteuse qui s'appelle quantya
c'est vous et un cascadeur qui s'appelle
james bataille voilà alors dit son
arrivée james bataille séduit concha qui
veut devenir chanteuse
poussé par son père le patron du bar qui
est joué par jean-pierre marielle voilà
mais la fête se termine en catastrophe à
et parallèlement un météorite s'écrase
sur scott let libérant d'étranges choses
volante gens les pieuvres de pierre
volante avait comme dans les films
américains des années 50 et la démarque
l'imprésario alan chiasse joué par
benoît poelvoorde
qui drague vanessa c'est un pitch assez
bien ce que je disais cervinia sq
lorsque je propose d'abord avant toute
chose mais ça c'est que vous regardiez
votre caméra et que vous dites magnéto
serge on va voir à quoi ça ressemble 6